[Music]
welcome back new efforts this morning to
stop Texas from defending itself from
the floating barrier installed back in J
crossing the border illegally Texas has
B uh borne much of the brunt of Biden's
open border policy which has seen a
record 8 million illegal border
crossings under the Biden Administration
border sources telling Fox News as Griff
Jenkins for the fiscal year nearly
475,000 migrants have been encountered
at the border with just over an
additional 60,000 getaways this is just
since the end of October in addition to
the floating barrier and in an effort to
alleviate the drain on financial and
social resources in Texas the governor
has also sent nearly 70,000 migrants on
buses to Sanctuary cities across the
country joining me right now with the
state's response is Texas governor Greg
Abbot Governor thanks very much for
joining us this morning always a
pleasure thank you Maria H how will you
respond to this Federal appeals court
demanding you remove those buoys from
the river
gr listen listen with with all due
respect the appeals court got it wrong
and the reason is because they relied
upon a law more than 100 years old uh
saying that we could not deploy these
buoys in the water preventing people
from entering the United States
illegally uh because the the Waterway uh
is categorized as a navigable Waterway
which is absurd uh because it is not nav
navigable by definition when you have uh
literally thousands of people able to
walk across it every single day it's not
used for Trans a of boats up and down
that Riverway and so it's completely not
navigable uh we had uh a a majority
Democrats who were on that panel making
that decision what Texas is going to be
doing and we will be seeking what's
called an unbun ruling by the entire
fifth SEC court of appeals and if we
lose there we will be taking that to the
United States Supreme Court because we
know Texas has the right to legally
deploy those buoys in the water to
prevent people from entering our country
and our state illeg Al so you're not
backing down and you're prepared to take
this all the way up to the Supreme Court
then absolutely okay let me get your
take on the assessment today of the uh
Southern border we know that we've seen
new numbers of wouldbe terrorists coming
through what can you tell us about the
apprehensions today is it the worst it's
been or has it been alleviated a
bit well I'll tell you a couple of
things very interesting for for one the
the problem is extraordinarily bad the
number are high in is because Joe Biden
continues to uh lay out the welcome at
welcoming illegal immigrants into the
United States of America that said uh
what we've seen in our numbers in the
state of Texas is uh because of the wall
that we have built because of these
razor wire barriers that we have built
uh Texas is now no longer uh the number
one IL illegal entry point uh it is uh
the Tucson sector the San Diego sector
uh in other states uh and in Texas is
causing the cartels to have to alter uh
their roots that uh their their routes
where people are coming across the
border illegally that said Texas is
having to step up and do even more uh to
make sure that we deny illegal entry
into the state of Texas and as a result
uh Maria in two weeks I'll be signing a
new law in the state of Texas uh that
will make it illegal for people to enter
the state of Texas from another country
illegally and authorizing every peace
officer in the state of Texas to arrest
those people entering our country
illegally well well what you just said
is so critical telling us that this
crisis has gone beyond Texas it's not
just Texas now you're talking about
Arizona being a critical issue we're
going to talk with Carrie Lake about
that coming up but I want to get your
take on on what you're going to do as
this court process plays out in other
words you're going to leave those buoys
in place until the court process plays
out when you take it uh when you go back
to the federal Appeals court and then
possibly the Supreme
Court so Maria not only are are we
intending to try to keep the buoys
remain in place but we continue to be
adding more barriers uh Maria we either
have already built or have under
construction uh more border wall uh than
what the Trump Administration was able
to put up uh we are building these razor
wire uh barriers with National Guards
standing behind them uh preventing
illegal entry uh and we will be passing
this law to arrest illegal immigrants
coming into the state of Texas and so we
as a state continue to deploy more
action fighting back against the B
administration's open border policies
doing everything we can to prevent
illegal entry into our country Governor
what can you tell us about these Chinese
Nationals that are Crossing into the
country I'm not sure if you heard my
conversation with Christine Nome a
moment ago but this China threat is
getting worse and worse she's worried
about the food supply but we are all
wondering why so many many Chinese
Nationals who are military AED men are
using the southern border to enter into
America right now what can you tell us
about that listen well first it it is
extraordinarily dangerous because first
of all as you point out we have uh
people from China com in here we also
have people on the uh known terrorist
watch list who are coming across the
border and so there's extraordinary
dangers caused to our country by Biden's
open border policies and obviously Biden
is doing nothing about it and that's why
Texas is having a step up and apprehend
as many of these people as possible uh
to make sure that they're not posing a
threat to our country but this is a a
very serious existential threat to our
country caused by Joe Biden and that's
exactly why Texas is taking
extraordinary steps to try to crack down
on it and and you know we just showed
these new uh migrant numbers as of the
end of November I mean this is just such
a short period of time and we're seeing
the num Spike uh in in the the new
fiscal year I know last week you were
with President Trump you endorsed
president Trump tell me about that
meeting why you had the 45th president
in in Texas uh to talk about what was
going on we were in a much different
situation under the Trump
Administration well you're exactly right
and so uh president Trump joined uh me
on uh just before Thanksgiving to thank
the troops that Texas has On the Border
serving them Thanksgiving meals and I uh
endorse president Trump at the time uh
for the simple reason that Americans
need to remember uh it was just four
years ago under President Trump that we
had the lowest illegal border crossings
in 40 years and we we had that low
number of Crossings because president
Trump put into place four very simple
policies the remaining Mexico policy the
title 42 policy the end of catching
release and the building of the border
wall and maybe you can add to that the
fact that President Trump said listen if
you want to come to America legally you
can do so legally if you're trying to
come here illegally you're not welcome
to be coming here what I do know is that
President Trump if he is reelected as
president of the United States because
he has proven the ability to stop people
from coming here illegally he will be
able to achieve that and res and restore
normaly and safety at our border and
push back and deny the illegal entry of
terrorist of the Chinese and people who
pose a danger to our country yeah it's
just extraordinary we were at a 40e low
under Trump and now we're at a 20-year
High under Biden were you surprised that
Marjorie Taylor Green's Bill to impeach
Alejandra mayorcas actually failed I
mean Alejandra mayorcas has told us
times that the border is
secure uh for one I am surprised that it
failed uh because if ever there was
anybody impeachable it would be mayorcas
for two reasons one he he's failed to do
his job in the executive branch he's
failed to execute the laws of of the
United States of America that unto
itself is an impeachable offense but
also because of his repeated lies to the
United States Congress about the Safety
and Security of the Border he he
deserves to be immediately removed from
office Governor thanks very much for
your leadership on this we are watching
this closely and of course we recognize
the national security threat that exists
thank you sir thank you Maria Texas
governor Greg Abbott joining us this
morning in Texas I'm Steve duy I'm Brian
kilme and that means aart and click here
to subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
page to catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling
analysis